pogchamps 3 is brought to you by grip 6.
grip 6 is an american manufacturing company
dedicated to making the very best belts
wallets and wool socks grip 6 built to wear
not to wear out visit grip6.com pogchimps
sorry i'm vibing right now to epic tunes whatever
you need to do to prepare this is my preparing
oh god okay cool so we got to starting off with
the white pieces michelle with the black pieces
she is starting off with the sicilian do you
like the system that she chose for beginners
i think it is going to be i feel like she's
learned the moves you know not only is she
playing the sicilian i'm sure she actually knows
how to play the sicilian too because with just
how much effort and fracture she's put in she's
smiling she seems to be you know pretty confident
uh with this opening and d5 she's already taking
a little bit of control in the center and tubbo
is actually going to be he's gonna stop bopping
his head he was we saw him quite visibly cad
jamming now now he's gonna pause a little bit oh
she's hovering the bishop hovering the rook now
f5 and that's going to be up a full
rook for michelle if she sees it
oh no she's going through every single piece
though that's the good news we might land on
the f-bond for sure and let's say that tubbo
doesn't see f5 let's pretend it didn't exist
because you know that's what's been happening so
far we're just gonna roll with it um another idea
that he would have to have i guess is to just
develop his queen and his rook this is what we
think of usually as the basics um otherwise it's
a hard position to play because it's so closed off
michelle is gonna struggle with that bishop on
c8 so he is doing oh no he blundered a rook i was
gonna say he's doing the principles but they're
not good here oh no now the question is does
michelle see either f5 or queen takes e4 f5 as
possible is up for grabs for the fourth fifth move
half the game yeah but you
know sometimes when you have
oh she plays it oh but here queen c3 is
actually a move that's really good i just don't
know okay all right you gotta think of queens oh
okay i can move my horse there and threaten the
queen so then the queen has to move and then
i can sacrifice my horse then i can damn it
no i moved my queen i now can't get the check ah
what check did he want um that's a good question
the other problem is if he plays 95 the rook
on e4 is hanging but it's hard to see i do
like the fact that he saw knight e5 at least
it's a good idea wait a minute he sees that
let's do that they move that pawn i take that
pawn it's mate so then they wouldn't yank
oh i'm so happy that your
tactics coaching paid off
do you think it's better to take the night or
try to run here if you're trying to survive i
think if she's gonna go for a stalling tactic king
h8 is probably better but at this point she might
as well take the knight and hope she can oh okay
so she has gone for the stalling tactic however
um she is down a piece as of the moment and toppo
can choose to just move the night away yeah maybe
we should take a look at double let's see what
he's thinking since he finally has the upper
hand in this game um he has to be a little bit
careful though because his knight is under attack
i think he's giving himself a pep talk
but tomorrow you don't have that much time
you mean you haven't ever tried karaoke during
a chess game i should probably say if this is
down although yeah sometimes you're right
nemo yeah i mean i you know what tubbo was
very happy and michelle was also very happy
at the start of the game oh my gosh okay it is
czech and the rook on e1 is protected but if he
moves his knight or something like that okay no
no no i there's always that last trick right
it's never over till it's over yeah for sure
and he hasn't jumped out of his chair too i'm
just like watching him he's like he's done a whole
workout over there oh my gosh this is really
impressive um you know i love there's still
many ideas so yep it's never over until it's
over guys so if he's trying to if she's trying
to get a stalemate here she should try to go for
something like f4 yes oh my gosh if he pushes g4
or he takes okay so now she has h4 and h5 these
are the two squares he does he has still once this
this event though oh no h5 if she pushes h5 next
move that would be incredible to try and trick
tubbo i do want to mention um instead of playing
gtx f4 there was actually checkman and one with
rook to a5 oh he's going for the he's going for
it awesome wow all right there is uh checkmating
two with rook g5 and rook takes h6 there's one
still mini move here that would be if double plays
bishop to d8 hopefully he does not yep and holds
that square that's the one way to can draw i don't
think he's gonna play it it'd be really cute if he
plays h4 for something to take and then checkmates
but we're not you know going for aesthetics we
just want to see some clean results there's you
can play anything and black's just in zug's one
um and then all right yep there you go beautiful
yeah you're right anything is a win here
anything except that one there's a team
oh yeah of course about there's maiden one
all right and the first game yes taken
by tuppo in this match played very very
and we got michelle starting off with a london
system who taught her this nemo um is it possibly
andrea i don't know uh andrea maybe but i i
michelle has had a ton of coaches and um so
i'm guessing somebody else taught her because we
only worked on some time it's definitely not me
i i do not advocate for people playing the london
um i am a big fan of e4 first move but the london
is a very good opening let's maybe take a listen
to michelle and see what she's thinking here
because it could be a critical position yes
yes all right she saw it nice job michelle
oh no the rook damn it okay oh god oh but i
have a point wait i don't know she's worrying
a little bit about that but i think she
doesn't maybe she just doesn't realize
that it's just gonna be a straight exchange
either way she doesn't lose any material yeah
i i think this is good he's creating a pawn
chain he saw the threat he's responding he
still has his knight in the center that he
will actually have to take with the rook
after um which might be a little bit tricky to see
so i think there's a good chance that if michelle
decides to take his knight if tubble plays d
takes e4 too quickly oh okay oh wait that's
going to cause some problems here why why is this
changing the evaluation bar so quickly well double
players bringing in his queen and his rook to
just kind of go for a checkmate attack here i
do think after bishop takes f3 um you can't even
take on f3 because after g takes f3 queen to g5
your only move is king of one and there it will
be knight to d2 which actually forks the queen so
and if you go king to h1 of course there
is knight takes f2 which is checkmate so
this is a very rough position for michelle
to be in and tumble is just going for the
attack so naturally like he he thought for
like half a second on bishop takes f3 and
the thing about this tactic is it's obviously a
long variation to see but they're very natural
moves so if michelle decides to recapture bringing
in your queen for a check is very tempting
and then it'll be up to tubbo to see once the king
moves if he sees that knight tactic um yeah i'm
i'm curious oh my gosh let's go to double screen
he does see queen g5 double tactics champ you guys
he has not been skipping his daily puzzles
no he has not time to raise ourselves
it's freedom like you never knew singing
tumble is popping up in a flash
you say my hat is off to you
but
okay so let's see if tubble's still gonna go
i mean he's still totally winning here
checkmate anymore because the king can escape
the f1 and rook d1 that's very close
whoa
he doesn't need to beat himself up over
that move it was still perfectly fine
oh no okay tubble has made into
tumble stop beating yourself up
okay you guys if he plays queen g5 queen g2 oh
okay let's actually i want to go back to tubbo
i want to see if he realizes it's made in one
he was so busy being upset are we gonna see this
oh it's been played he got upset and then he just
slurped his drink no reaction oh oh there it is
there he even realizes that was fruity that was
brutal i'm sorry oh my god that was so brutal
i'm so sorry i no you did awesome oh my gosh
apologizing for that i swear i've never i've never
played chess like this before i swear this is a
first for me we're gonna ask you guys a little
bit more about your emotions but we just wanted to
show you a very important part in the first game
michelle kudos to you for being the first between
the two of you to find the fork on f5 attacking
the rook in the night that had been there for a
while and you found it we were all super proud
thank you i wish i had founded a few moves earlier
but both of you guys played amazing i'm was very
impressed by queen c3 it was it's not a very
natural move so double actually what was your
thought process behind uh playing queen c3 process
was like oh i don't want to lose these two pieces
what can i do panic and i i thought that oh
i've got a checkmate um so i guess i'll use
that to try to save the castle true michelle also
you have probably one of the craziest resumes of
anyone here i mean you were a professional athlete
you went nuts youtube you're an actress how does
studying chess compare to all the other challenges
you've done it's so much harder it's so much
harder i mean everyone it's amazing like everyone
prepared so differently for this and everyone
prepared so well i know toppo says he doesn't know
an opening but clearly he knows what he's doing to
some degree or there's some secrets in the steel
drum i don't know what's going on there um but yes
um yeah it's it's really really hard i mean you
can prepare so much and then show up and then
forget everything or remember nothing i mean like
it it's very stressful um so much kudos to you
guys for doing this professionally and tubbo who
is obviously on his way to doing it professionally
yeah what are you going to announce you're
playing for a world championship title
uh well first off i don't even know what that
is well so both of you will be playing in
the consolation bracket and again a lot of the
people who made it to the championship bracket
have been playing chess for longer than you
two so you're going to be able to battle it
out do you guys have any different strategies
going into that maybe let's start with tubbo um
uh strategies i like my pins that is the thing we
did in like the last lesson it's the only thing
i've managed to retain so i'm using the pins the
pins okay that sounds good what about you michelle
anything you think you're gonna change
with your approach towards the consolation
pairings yeah i'm going to order
an ukulele and a steel drum
literally yesterday i ordered a bat and a acoustic
uh electro baritone ukulele you should get one
okay i'm going to get one what acoustic ukulele
but you can hook it up to an amp but it's baritone
yeah i think maybe gets hello
i feel like tubbo's energy that he gets from all
of his instruments and his surroundings really go
into his chest well tubbo michelle you guys
were both such good sports and you played some
really good games the positions today were very
close so we were commentating and it felt very
tough but we do wish both of you the best of
luck in the consolation bracket thank you so
much